200 من والله من يشد علي الله طول الليل
وانا بعيط من السقعه ومن القشريه اللي فيا
ومن الجوع ومن الحزن اللي انا فيه ولا قرش
معايا ولا شاكل معايا الا وجه الله الكريم
انا بدي غزه اروح فيها انا والله انا متت
هنا انا والله متت وشفت الزل
هنا حدش كان متوقف اصلا انه ممكن طلعتنا
هذه تطول اكثر من اسبوع ع ايام
كبيرها وقلنا حنرجع
هنا اليوم خشينا في الشهر 10 و11 و1
وواحد وخشينا في الاربعينيه لما كان يقول
خذوا اواعي معكم حيجي الشتاء وتسقط انا في
صحرا مش زي الصحراء ما فيش مقارنه اصلا ما
بين الخيمه وما بين البيت انت ببيتك بقيت
عايش زوجتك واولادك ثلاجه
تلفزيون كهرباء مي حمام حياه ثاني انت
اليوم هان اذا بدك تتحمم بدك تعمل مليون
حساب للحمام اللي بدك تتحمل من السقعه في
حال ما يكون في صوت طيران واجواء حرب
والكلام هذا يعني بحاول اهدئ من روع
الاطفال الموجودين حوالي اطمنهم فانت نفسك
قاعد بتهدف الطفل الصغير وانت نفسك عارف
انه انت انت ممكن تطير انت والطفل صغير
بيكفي قتل بيكفي موت احنا شعب بستاهل
الحياه احنا بني ادمين زينا زيكم وتعملوا
بندوره ولا بس علبتين الفول
هذول اليوم بتعيش وضع صعب جدا جدا معناه
بنحط على حالنا احرامات وبرغم من كل هذا
ما فيش ما تدفش لانه كمان يعني ما في يعني
كل واحد مثلا بطانيه او احرام او حاجه ما
في يعني الكميه محدوده فبتحب يعني هيك انه
ننام جنب بعض كل
هيتنا انا عندي ع ت انفار فسرتي سبع اولاد
وبنت وانا ومرتي ع انفار وامي واخواتي
ثلاثه بنات بنوت 13 نفر تخلقت خيمه ثلاثه
في اربعه ومن غير فرشات وبنام على هالبلاد
بس الحرام علينا لا في شمع ولا في كاز ولا
في بنزين في هالبلد الولد على الدب بصحى
بصوت البنت بتصحى على الدب وعلى الخبط
وعلى الطخ بتصوت ياما قولي يا رب احنا
لوقت ت الحال
هذا خيم عايشين في قلب نايلون وفي الليل
البلد والله ما بنصدق الا يطلع الصبح عشان
تيجي الشمس جووه البرد معي ثلاث اطفال
اولادي وكنت انا لحالي جايه ومش عارفه
مكان اهلي كان مكانهم مش معروف الي ولا
مالوف يعني كانت الح حياه صعبه انه بدنا
نروح على الحمام نخاف بدنا نطلع من واحنا
نايمين بالليل نضلنا خايفين يعني طول
الليل بظلهم يحكوا لي يا ماما احنا
خايفين القصف والصوت شيء مش لحد الان مش
قادرين نتا قلم كل يوم نحكي اذا قعدنا يوم
كمان بالخيمه هنموت مرحله صعبه يعني قد ما
نحكي صعبه مش هنقدر نوصف الالم اللي احنا
عايشينه يعني اودي طول الليل بضلني ارجف
وقاعده ادعي ربنا انه المي والشتا ما
ينزلش علينا يرجعنا